قالت المتحدثه باسم قياده عمليات الجنوب
في الجيش الاوكراني التاليه ان القوات
الروسيه قصفت مقاطعتي
بالصواريخ والطائرات المسيره ليلى امس
مستهدفه منشات
ومناطق سكنيه حسب قولها
لليله الثالثه على التوالي هاجمت القوات
الروسيه مناطق اوديسا وميكولايف مستهدفه
البنيه التحتيه للموانئ واستخدمت الصواريخ
والطائرات المسيره ما ادى الى وقوع اصابات
واضرار في مباني سكنيه ومنشات لوجستيه
ومستودعات ما زالت المعلومات قيد التحقق
لكننا نعلم ان القوات الروسيه اطلقت
الصواريخ من قواعد مختلفه وشاركت في
الهجوم غواصه كانت تعمل في البحر الاسود
وطيران من استراتيجي وانظمه صواريخ من نوع
اونيكس ويحتمل ان تكون من بينها صواريخ من
طراز اسكندر